wie viel Geld kann man an einem Tag mit
einem lemonate Stand verdienen also bin
ich erstmal in den nächstbesten Kiosk
gegangen um zu erfragen welche Produkte
sich am besten verkaufen
aus dem Kiosk direkt in den Großhandel
und dort für 90 € Getränke gekauft mit
tischschild und Kühlbox habe ich mich
dann in den Park gestellt und auf
Kundschaft gewartet leider wollte
niemand irgendwas kaufen was ich
vielleicht so ein bisschen verstehen
etwas durfte her sind sie durstig also
muss ich meine Taktik ändern
anstatt die Getränke zu verkaufen
verschenke ich sie einfach und sammelt
eine Spende für eine Rolex
das ist ein guter Mann
plötzlich waren die Leute bereit mir bis
zu 5 € zu geben weil sie ist lustig
fanden oder so und sogar eine echt Gold
Creole war dabei doch tatsächlich was
lernen wir daraus keine Ahnung aber wir
haben 87 € verdient und damit die Frage
beant